on est quatre potes à cheval c'est à
quatre pattes se lâche et chacun une pax
et reprend la patte avant droite tout
autant fifi deux secondes peut-être une
affaire pour toi oui oui c'est peut-être
deux vainqueurs tout ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher ses habitations
moi je suis là en gros la faire il était
une fois 4 potier comme les doigts de la
main qui vivait au jour le jour on
attend d'un petit coup de pouce du
destin s'est dit qu'est ce que les
turfistes les trouve des vulgarités
salle même le poteau qui était sacré les
gars sait plus aujourd'hui si je crois
que je suis allé à monsieur delgado
question comment on fait pour le jockey
manette
audi conserve tous vos manettes tout cet
argent à cheval il faut pas voir ce que
ça coûte il faut voir ce que ça rapporte
je les enfants abusés à papa qui est
très fatigué les dents si encore de
l'eau et hop tout le monde au lit je les
trouvais bizarre je suis sûr que
l'endroit est encore tous des endroits
du parti et nulle part donc en gros on a
acheté après tôt avec une langue qui
pensent comme une divine
on sait que moi aussi j'ai fait du
cheval ge est égal aux deux ânes ucp le
batteur qu'il fallait envisager
l'inenvisageable quoi j'ai un pote de
boucher on va voir ce qui va et vient
nana mouskouri n'allez pas vous battre
quand même domaine pas de sa carrière
m'adresse nous avions misé sur le bon
cheval et ses pattes à palettes et à
prendre en compte est là et fifi qu'est
ce que tu as tout propriétaire d'un
cheval et le prince albert il vend des
choux sur la plage on est ami de trente
ans tu es mon frère réduit à gratter ce
matin alors qu'ils jouent parce que
sinon comme on dit chez nous jours de
pertes veille d'un corps et avec ça